[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of times when you see a coach
going off the sidelines at halftime
there's an understanding that the
sideline reporter is going to get two
questions sometimes it's only one maybe
it's three there's a discussion maybe
pregame if you're going to talk to the
coach and uh I was wondering with Jenny
Taff she was working the sidelines with
uh Penn State in Michigan and Jen joins
us now at what point did you realize
that Harbaugh wasn't going to be there
and how much prep work did you have on
what you were going to talk to him about
well first of all thanks for having me
on this is uh really special to be a
part of the show so thank you and you
know it was one of those situations Dan
where you're not I've never been in a
situation like this before where
oftentimes the broadcast has a lot more
information going into the game maybe
the public doesn't know we had no idea
if Harbaugh was going to show up minutes
before the game and throughout the week
we had had a conversation with Coach
Harbaugh and he said if for some reason
there's I am not able to coach it will
be Chiron more so we knew that going
into it but they had they really did not
believe that that was going to be the
situation so I felt a little bit like an
investigative reporter on Saturday
morning and yeah you're always looking
at body language and talking to players
and coaches and it was just a different
energy because no one knew I interviewed
Chiron Moore during warm-ups when they
still didn't know if harb could
potentially show up and obviously the
mood continued to shift so I I know
Chiron more and I've gotten to know him
pretty well over the years and he had a
calm confidence to the way he was
carrying himself but then when he
realized he was going to be the guy I
did feel like he tensed up and you could
just sense that it was a big opportunity
for him okay let's say Harbaugh showed
up what was your question going to be
prior to the game oh gosh first of all
Harbaugh I have it's been years for me
convincing him to do these interviews so
as you know he doesn't love them but I
would have chased him down and said
coach the last 24 hours have been insane
you've been in your hotel room what has
been going through your mind and how are
you prepared to win this game today I
think the the issue is and I've been
asked this do you ask about the
allegations in that moment and I tend to
believe that you have to allow the game
to play out and perhaps after a win I
would have taken that opportunity to
congratulate him on the win had they won
with harba coaching I assume it would
have been the same outcome there and
then you possibly give him the
opportunity to address a different
audience because he's spoken about it
you know in his press conferences but I
would try to give him that moment but as
we all know with Harbaugh and as shiron
Moore did the same they like to start
the interview and then hand them off to
a player so I'm kind of used to that
when it comes to Michigan what do you
expect is harble on the sidelines this
weekend boy I I have a feeling yes just
based on how confident they seem to be
uh obviously we know that that hearing
is set for Friday and I'm sure you saw
some of his quotes yesterday from his
presser saying that he's watched plenty
of Judge Judy and he's prepared for his
big moment I mean he had an alltime list
of quotes yesterday that I just to say
that Harbaugh is not stressed about this
it's kind of crazy but I don't think he
really is and he said to us over and
over again and this is what he is
telling us I did not know what was going
on and you know he's handled the
pressure and he said to me I don't want
the players to deal with this let
everyone come my way so harba knows the
hard questions are coming uh he hasn't
decided as of yesterday if he will speak
on Friday but if he's not there Chiron
Moore will continue and after what we
saw from Saturday and the way he was
able to do both manage that offense and
lead the team I thought it was pretty
impressive we had Brady Quinn on
yesterday and I said and he he was
talking about this too could you set up
a camera where I I was more interested
in watching Harbaugh watch the game than
I would have been watching the game
itself but is there any chance that you
could do an interview with him or even
the broadcasters could do an interview
with him if he's watching from a hotel
room oh I mean you better believe I'm
going to ask I actually did ask that
question if we could send a camera to
the hotel I was shut down by Michigan
which I understand I mean at that point
they don't even know and I'm like where
is he watching oh he's in the hotel room
I said with who like is he watching solo
and just pacing like Harbaugh watching a
game in his hotel room should have been
just like a steady cam video we were
going to on the side so look I guess we
don't know until Friday takes place but
I know that fox will do whatever we can
to make sure we have some sort of
harbuck ham and I will do my best to get
all that inside scoop and he is going to
talk to me if he's there he can't say no
to me this time do you know that for
sure well I mean I'm going to make it
very clear to him because like you have
to talk and I've given him this out in
the past but at the same time like coach
Hara you gotta talk now so it's too big
of a news story and hopefully he he
understands that plus he's playing the
victim and now he's the coach of
America's team and yeah that's what he
said America's team right and I I don't
I know he doesn't like doing interviews
because I know he wants the attention to
be about the players but this is
different and I do think he understands
that now so I don't worry when we get
off this this I'm going to text
Michigan's Sid and make sure we're
prepared for for all interviews well
they're probably watching writing down
all of this we're talking to Jenny tap
she'll be on the sidelines Fox big noon
Saturday and it'll be Michigan and
Maryland then uh it'll be Ohio State in
Michigan the following Saturday oh my
god um yeah how physical does it get on
the sidelines for you what do you you
mean you know postgame joshing trying to
get a coach camera people you know it's
pretty intense uh look I I think back on
Michigan Ohio State a couple years ago
when Michigan had finally gotten the
wind an arbor snow coming down I'm
trying to find Aiden Hutchinson I'm
actually pregnant at the time which is
wild considering some of my security
guards were like we don't want you to do
the interview of the storming of the
field and I'm like you think I'm going
to miss this interview like there's no
way so yeah at times it's a little
intense but that's half the reason why I
love the energy of being a sideline
reporter I think you feel it in a
different way when you're on the field
and you're chasing down coaches we tend
to have a plan right like had Penn State
one I would have tried to find coach
Franklin to the side like at some point
you have to a little bit map it out
because if you don't want to miss the
coach that's the worst case in any field
storming situation um but yeah it gets
physical but at the same time it's kind
of what I love about it and and I would
never turn down any of those interviews
like I Sprint to get to that coach as
fast as I can when when the game ends
and yeah Chiron did I anticipate the
tears no I felt he was starting to feel
it like it was sinking in right before
we had kind of chatted and then once he
started to get a little emotional I you
know I soaked it up a little bit and I I
felt like I didn't anticipate the
swearing uh he actually did text me
right after which I thought was really
sweet he said I'm so sorry I got
emotional I'm sorry about the F bombs
but like I couldn't help myself and I
think that that just speaks to the
emotion of college football like it's so
it's just they had been through a lot
and it was a big deal for him loudest
stadium you've been
in the big house is hard to top it
really is and now I I'm just talking
about Michigan but like you know I was
pretty impressed by Bieber Stadium this
was our second game uh at Penn State and
I I will say that the way it's
set up it's just a really impressive fan
base and crowd and I haven't had a night
game there but we've just really enjoyed
going to Happy Valley and like that
crowd is it's pretty special being a
journalist can you confirm this that
Brady Quinn does a party pump before he
goes on on the show on big noon kickoff
I mean what does it Brady does it all
right like Brady is what can't he do he
got stopped twice on our way home for
autographs like this guy like it's just
he can't he can't get away from being
Brady Quinn and I he's a great teammate
I'm actually so lucky to to work with a
guy like him I know he comes on the show
often so I should have texted him for
some insight he seems like he could be
high maintenance though you know hair
makeup well it's just one of those like
when he looks better than me that's just
not a great sign for like a broadcast
crew I feel like I try to put myself
together and then I to Brady Quinn and
like you can't you do what you can yeah
I know it's not fair that's why he's
called Brady Brady uh good luck this
weekend we'll be watching thanks for
joining us congrats on your your baby
too thank you J thank you uh Jenny Taff
she'll be on the sidelines there looking
for Jim Harbaugh it's Michigan and
Maryland and then Ohio State in Michigan
the following Saturday it's a job that
your your job is to make it look easy
smooth fluid and it's not because it can
be choppy and chaotic and survival
especially when the fans storm the field
and then you're just looking you're
looking you're looking your camera
person's there and you're just you
there's this you know sea of people and
you're trying to do your job and the
fans are running by and yelling and
screaming they want to be on camera uh
it it's chaos it's it's disorganized
chaos I was going to say organized chaos
but there's nothing organized about that